-Chloe, go to the mic
and let's see what you'll
be playing tonight.
-Okay.
-Alright.
Don't be scared.
I have faith.
Oh, it's a mix tape
medley showdown.
Here we go.
-♪ Let me have your
favorite song ♪
♪ Mixtape medley ♪
♪ Showdown ♪
-Alright,
since this is a showdown,
we're going to need to mics.
Chloe and Halle
are going to face off
against each other
in this challenge.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, Halle, come up here.
Here's how Mixtape Medley
Showdown works.
I'm going to spin the wheel,
and I'm going to give you
the title of a mixtape,
then you'll have to go
back and forth
singing a medley of those songs.
Let's see what you got.
-Okay.
[ Cheering ]
-Ooh.
-Okay.
The theme is breakup songs.
That means the band
will play a medley
of the best breakup songs
of all time,
and we'll see how well
you can keep up.
Take your spots.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You got this. You got this.
-Who's going to start? I think
Chloe will start up first.
Whenever you're ready.
-Okay.
-Good luck, guys.
♪♪
Okay.
♪ I'm a survivor ♪
♪ I'm not gon' give up ♪
♪ I'm not gon' stop ♪
♪ I'm gon' work harder ♪
♪ I'm a survivor ♪
♪ I'm gonna make it ♪
♪ I will survive ♪
♪ Keep on survivin' ♪
-♪ Why'd you have to go and make
things so complicated? ♪
♪ I see the way you're ♪
♪ Actin' like you're somebody
else, gets me frustrated ♪
♪ Life's like this, you ♪
♪ And you fall, and you
crawl, and you break ♪
♪ And you take what you get
and you turn it into ♪
♪ Honesty and promise me, I'm
never gonna find you fake it ♪
♪ No, no, no ♪
-♪ No matter what I do ♪
♪ All I think about is you ♪
♪ Even when I'm with my boo ♪
♪ You know I'm crazy over you ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ I dug my key into the side ♪
♪ Of his pretty little
souped up four-wheel drive ♪
♪ Carved my name
into his leather seats ♪
♪ I took a Louisville slugger
to both headlights ♪
♪ Slashed a hole
in all four tires ♪
♪ Maybe next time, he'll think
before he cheats ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Maybe next time, he'll think ♪
♪♪
-♪ You can go your own way,
go your own way ♪
♪ You can call it
another lonely day ♪
♪ Hey, you can go your own way ♪
♪ Go your own way ♪
-♪ We are never, ever,
ever getting back together ♪
♪ We are never, ever,
♪ You go talk to your friends,
talk to my friends, talk to me ♪
♪ But we are never, ever, ever,
ever getting back together ♪
-♪ Well, good for you ♪
♪ You look happy and healthy,
not me ♪
♪ If you ever cared to ask ♪
♪ Good for you ♪
♪ You're doin' great out there
without me, baby ♪
God, I wish that
I could do that
I've lost my mind,
I've spent the night
Cryin' on the floor
of my bathroom
♪ But you're so unaffected,
I really don't get it ♪
♪ But I guess good for you ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ But since you been gone ♪
♪ I can breathe
for the first time ♪
♪ I'm so moving on,
yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Thanks to you ♪
♪ Now I get, I get what I want ♪
-♪ Since you been gone ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!
That's how you do it
right there!
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, standing ovation
right there.
Come on back.
Whoo, that's gotta feel good.
A standing O right there.
Oh, my gosh.
Both of you, unbelievable.